a pocos kilómetros de la frontera con
rusia se encuentra en la ciudad
finlandesa de imatra el nerviosismo por
la invasión rusa de ucrania se ha
sentido más aquí que en otros lugares de
finlandia con muchos residentes
aliviados por la intención del país de
unirse a la otan lo turbado estado es
seguro vivir aquí pero cuando empezó la
guerra en ucrania empecé a preguntarme
que si algún día estaríamos en la misma
situación ya que estamos tan cerca de la
frontera
deberíamos habernos unido antes no tiene
sentido alargarlo más llevamos años
viendo lo que pasa en el exterior
incluso antes de la guerra de ucrania y
mattrah tenía una relación complicada
con rusia los dolorosos recuerdos de la
invasión rusa durante la segunda guerra
mundial todavía están presentes
pero siempre se ha temido a rusia a lo
largo de los tiempos siempre hemos
estado de alerta y hemos desconfiado una
de las euro lamento está pero en esta
zona tenemos interacciones todos los
días
alrededor de mil residentes tienen la
nacionalidad rusa y muchos cruzaban la
frontera con regularidad antes de que se
cerrara a una distancia de 210 km san
petesburgo están más cerca de la ciudad
que la capital finlandesa helsinki pero
un enlace ferroviario previsto entre la
ciudad rusa y mattrah y muchos otros
proyectos transfronterizos se han
cancelado por la guerra